[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy andrés suárez jaramillo
calificada como la última oportunidad
que tienen las naciones para frenar el
progresivo calentamiento global la cob
26 es decir la cumbre de las naciones
unidas sobre el cambio climático que
este año 2021 se celebra en glasgow
tiene un papel crucial para el futuro
del clima de nuestro planeta estas
cumbres que se abrevian con las siglas
cop llevan más de un cuarto de siglo
evaluando e intentando amortiguar el
efecto de la acción humana sobre el
clima sin embargo al día de hoy sigue
habiendo controversia en torno a su
efectividad de manera que hagamos un
repaso la primera copa fue celebrada en
berlín en
1995 aquí se reconoció por primera vez
que había un problema con el
calentamiento global y que estaba en
manos del ser humano el poder cambiarlo
berlín introdujo la necesidad de que las
naciones del mundo se reunieran cada año
para hablar sobre el clima con discursos
hasta entonces poco escuchados como el
que pronunció la pobre entonces ministra
de medio ambiente alemana angela merkel
día en nosotros en las naciones
industrializadas debemos cambiar
nuestras ideas de lo que vemos como la
buena vida traen dan en el inicio de
estas cumbres por el clima los
principales actores internacionales
llamados a actuar fueron por supuesto
los países industrializados estas
naciones llevaban más de un siglo
emitiendo gases contaminantes a la
atmósfera debido a su temprana
industrialización y eran los principales
considerados los principales causantes
del aumento de las temperaturas el
progresivo deshielo de los polos y el
consecuente aumento del nivel del mar
las peticiones lanzadas durante las
primeras conferencias tuvieron su
respuesta en la cop 3 de kioto realizada
en el año
1997 las conclusiones de este acto
dieron como resultado el protocolo de
kioto un acuerdo histórico en el que los
países firmantes se comprometieron a
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero en al menos un 5% para 2012
desde los niveles de 1990
entonces hasta 192 países ratificaron
este protocolo ilusionante en materia
medioambiental que en un principio
pareció comprometer a las grandes
potencias como eeuu por supuesto
eeuu sigue firmemente comprometido con
un objetivo fuerte y vinculante que
reducirá nuestras emisiones en casi un
30 por ciento de lo que serían y
con un compromiso tan fuerte o más
fuerte que cualquiera de los que hemos
escuchado aquí el imperativo aquí es
hacer lo que prometemos en lugar de
prometer lo que no podemos hacer
sin embargo kioto nunca cumplió las
expectativas depositadas es cierto que
se intentó regular las emisiones con
sanciones a los países que no cumplieran
el objetivo pero el principal escollo
fue la no ratificación de eeuu y la
posterior retirada de su firma en 2001
además algunas herramientas presentadas
como el mercado de compraventa de
permisos de emisión ayudó a las grandes
potencias a mantener o incluso aumentar
sus emisiones
por eso que vamos a analizar el
siguiente mapa en el cual podemos ver un
cuadro comparativo un cuadro de las
emisiones de co2 de los países en el año
2017 con respecto al año 1990 y es
especialmente llamativo el caso de los
países en vías de desarrollo en américa
latina áfrica o asia pero también se
observa que salvo con la excepción de
europa del este los estados
industrializados de europa norteamérica
y oceanía no cumplieron con lo marcado
en kioto la siguiente scope fueron
evidenciando progresivamente la falta de
intención de muchos países para hacer
vinculantes los acuerdos sobre el clima
algo que se reflejó especialmente en la
cop15 de copenhague en 2009 donde sólo
se puso como meta no superar en dos
grados celsius el aumento de la
temperatura algo que resultó claramente
insuficiente ya que entre los años 2011
y 2015 se registraron las temperaturas
más altas en la historia del planeta
en este contexto se afrontó la cob 21 de
la que surgió el acuerdo de parís de
este acuerdo contó con la ratificación
de hasta 191 países gracias a su
flexibilidad el acuerdo de parís dejó de
lado las obligaciones y sanciones
impuestas en kioto para apostar por que
cada país regule voluntariamente sus
emisiones el objetivo era que el máximo
número de naciones se comprometiera a
intentar ralentizar el calentamiento
global a un máximo de 2 grados celsius
para finales de siglo ya que superar
esta cifra supone cambios muy drásticos
en el clima que podrían llegar a ser no
reversibles y que implican inundaciones
sequías prolongadas o la destrucción de
los polos una meta complicada pero no
imposible ahora su principal obstáculo
fue de nuevo eeuu que aunque en
principio firmó y ratificó lo acordado
se retiró tras la llegada de donald
trump a la presidencia
el ahora el field
para cumplir con mi deber solemne de
proteger a los eeuu y a sus ciudadanos
the united states ue y
eeuu se retirará el acuerdo climático de
parís
yeimer con la marcha de eeuu bajo la
excusa de las consecuencias económicas
por las medidas supuso un duro golpe
para el acuerdo de parís ya que sólo
este país produce el 14 por ciento de
las emisiones globales pero su reciente
vuelta a su reingreso al acuerdo abre un
hilo de esperanza para el inicio de esta
cop 26 una posible última oportunidad
para evitar lo irreversible si se
consigue apostar por un cambio
vinculante que involucre al máximo
número de países así concluimos el texto
y la edición de esta crónica es trabajo
de álvaro cordero gracias por compartir
y comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]